What is socialism?
Socialism is a political and economic ideology
that advocates for social
ownership of the means of production.
It seeks to address the inequalities
and inefficiencies seen in capitalism
by redistributing wealth
and power more equitably among the population.
Unlike capitalism,
where resources and industries are privately owned
and operated for profit,
socialism emphasizes collective or public ownership.
At its core,
socialism aims to create a society where
the allocation of resources is based
not on market forces,
but on the needs and contributions of its members.
This involves a comprehensive system of
economic planning,
which contrasts with
the capitalist reliance on market mechanisms.
Socialism encompasses a spectrum of theories
and practices,
from democratic socialism
to more authoritarian models
that centralise power to enforce social ownership
and economic planning.
Despite its variations,
socialism's unifying goal remains
to reorganize society to promote Equality
and social welfare
above individual profit.